[Musique]
s'il vous plaît arrêtez de me rappeler que
quelque chose ne va pas Je sais de première main à quel point
cela s'est passé assez dur pour que Oh ne soit
pas mon même oh garçon tu peux me parler J'ai
essayé de te parler de ça depuis
une fois que je ne parle pas  à ce sujet profondément
ne se reproduira jamais dans les points chauds cela
ne se reproduira que mon
conseil professionnel oui vous n'arrêtez pas le
mal vous ne pouvez pas vous en protéger
c'est génial je ne le referai pas
j'ai un ballon qu'est-ce que tu es  qu'est-ce que
tu fais là-bas papa descends
je suis désolé
ce qui disparaît à travers n'importe quel
obèse imaginé précédemment
[Musique]
ce n'est pas vraiment assez pour toi Billy
toi